- [Man] January 1974.
They'd just moved in two months prior.
My partner and I were first on the scene.
He was feeling for a light
when something bumped him.
That's when we found the little
girl hanging from this pipe.
- [Man] Jesus.
- I found someone to take over,
who'll be very good for the BSU.
He wants to expand the unit
and he intends to make
our approach practice.
- Tell me, who's the one
you want more than anything?
- Manson.
- I'll get you Manson.
- This is $100,000.
And it's all yours if you
help us identify the persons
behind the murders of
our children in Atlanta.
- [Man] Another child
reported missing in Atlanta.
- I'm sending you both, I want
you there for the duration.
- [Man] For all these
children, one killer?
- I believe that to be the case.
It's statistically rare
for serial killers to cross racial lines.
- It's also statistically significant
that the Klan kills black people.
- [Woman] You get him out of there.
If he blows this, then we'll
rethink his investment.
- [Man] I'm asking you as the
leader of your department,
what did Holden say that
so offended the city?
- [Holden] We need to stay focused.
If you're distracted.
- [Man] I have some things
to deal with at home.
It's personal.
- She had someone else's
underwear stuffed down her throat.
- It's 10:30.
Do you know where your children are?
- This is one predator.
- What if you're wrong?
- I'm not.
- You arrogant, self-serving twerp.
- We can't have tunnel-vision, Holden.
- [Holden] What evidence is
there to suspect the Klan?
- Son, we've got 19 dead black children.
You telling me that's a coincidence?
- [Man] One more thing.
Manson is small, like really small.
Try not to stare.